[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle faisait le trottoir le long de
l'église il y a bien des curés qui
prient dans la rue elle avait 20 ans de
Loyau au service 20 ans de grande vie et
de petites vertus moi en ce temps-là
j'alis confesse tous les mercredis à 5h
etcart
j'étais le dernier à parler de fesses et
si j'y
pensais c'était par
hasard
mademoiselle de déshonneur mon premier
amour d'un quart
d'heure ce mercredi là j'étais en avance
j'avais déserté le cours de français et
j'allais me refaire une bonne
conscience lorsque j'entends dit tu
viens mon
biquet un coup d'œil
devant coup d'œil derrière j'étais le
seul biquet à s Liu
autour alors je suis venu en faisant ma
prière je voulais faire la
PE j'ai fait
l'amour
mademoiselle de déshonneur mon premier
amourun quart
d'heure et c'est là
bêtement dans cette chambre obscure
cette chambre sans joie sans fleur au
rideau c'est là que j'ai reçu ma
première blessure laisser mon enfance
porte
manteau on peut rêver mieux pour sa
grande
première de coucher de
soleil
de champ
mug moi je naai
récolté trois notres
pères 2 minutes
dormant zé de
français deoiselle de déshonneur mon
premier
amour quart
[Musique]
d'heur